>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Carla Hayden: Good morning
I'm Carla Hayden the Librarian
of Congress and I
want to welcome you
to this very special
story time at the library.
I love reading, don't you?
It's so much fun to let
our imaginations run wild.
We're excited to be teaming
up with Miss Dolly
Parton's Imagination Library
to introduce you to
some wonderful authors
who will share their
stories with us.
Ms. Parton's work through
her imagination library
is awe-inspiring.
She and her team have given away
over a hundred million books
to help encourage young readers
like you across the world.
Here at the Library of
Congress, we share that passion
for developing young readers
and we know that the best way
to encourage people like you
to read is to make reading fun.
So that's what we're here to do.
I hope you enjoyed
today's storytime,
even more I hope you keep
reading at home and having fun.
Today you will warm up
by singing some songs,
touching your toes, and
then get comfortable
and get ready to hear stories.
Now, let's get started.
>> Caroline Quandt: Hello,
welcome to the Library
of Congress in the
beautiful Music Division room.
So today we are welcoming,
we are celebrating the books
of Anna Dewdney one
of the most popular
and wonderful children's
illustrator,
authors of the 20th
century, 21st century.
She is no longer with
us but we're going
to celebrate her books today.
So, welcome all of
you out there.
My name is Caroline
and this is Thea
from the American
Folklife Center who's going
to help us read.
So let's start off today with
our Hello Song and we're going
to do some sign, so we say hello
by saluting, and then friends
as we hug our index fingers,
one way and then the other.
And then, so three times,
hello friends, hello friends,
it's time to say hello.
[Singing] Hello, hello,
friends hello friends.
Hello friends, it's
time to say hello.
Good job. [Applause] [Singing]
So let's do open shut them
to wake up our brains, all right
open shut them open shut them
give a little clap, clap clap.
Open shut them, open, shut them,
put them in your lap, lap, lap.
Creep them crawl them,
creep them crawl them,
right up to your
chin, chin, chin.
Open up your little mouth
but do not let them in.
One more time.
Open, shut them, open shut them,
give a little clap, clap, clap.
Open shut them, open shut them,
put them in your lap, lap, lap.
Creep them crawl them,
creep them crawl them right
up to your chin, chin, chin.
Open up your little mouth
but do not let them in.
Good job. [Applause] Alright,
here's our first book,
the classic, favorite,
Llama Llama, Red Pajama.
>> Thea Austen : Llama
llama Red Pajama, written
and illustrated by Anna Dewdney.
>> Child in Audience:
Llama Llama.
>> Thea Austen: Llama
llama, red pajama,
reads a story with his mama.
See, they're reading together.
Mama kisses baby's hair.
Mama llama goes downstairs.They
waved goodnight.
Llama llama red pajama feels
alone without his mama.
Baby llama wants a drink but
mama is at the kitchen sink.
Llama llama red pajama, calls
down to his llama mamma.
Mamma says she'll be up
soon, baby llama hums a tune.
Llama llama red pajama,
waiting, waiting for his mama.
Mama isn't coming yet.
Baby llama starts to fret.
Llama llama red pajama
whimpers softly for his mama.
Mama llama hears the phone.
Baby llama starts to moan.
Llama llama red pajama
listens quiet for his mama.
What is mama llama doing?
Baby llama starts boo-hoo-ing.
Llama llama red pajama
hollers loudly for his mama.
Baby llama stops and pouts,
baby llama jumps and shouts,
llama llama red pajama in
the dark with her his mama.
Eyes wide open, covers drawn,
what if mama llamas gone?
Llama llama red pajama
waiting for his mama.
Mama llama, will
his mama ever come?
Mama llama run run run!
She drops the phone oh my
goodness is something wrong?
She runs upstairs he
looks pretty okay.
Baby llama, what a tizzy.
Sometimes Mama's very busy.
Please stop all this llama drama
and be patient for your mama.
Little llama don't you know
mama mama loves you so.
Mama llamas always near even
if she's not right here.
Llama mama red pajama gets
two kisses from his mama.
[Kissing smacks] Snuggles
pillow, soft and deep,
baby llama goes to sleep.
[ Applause ]
>> Caroline Quandt: So what
was happening with baby llama?
He was so frustrated and waiting
and waiting for his mama.
He didn't like waiting no he
needs to learn to be patient
so now we're going to sing
a song about being patient.
And you can do it,
I know you can.
[Singing] I am patient I am
patient, I can wait, I can wait.
One, two, three, four, five, and
six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
I can wait, I am great.
One more time.
I am patient, I am patient,
I can wait, I can wait.
One, two, three, four, five, and
six, seven, eight, nine, ten,
I can wait, I am great.
Okay, that's great.
[Applause] Now we're going
to do a little action
rhyme about going to bed.
It's about love, we changed
it to make it about llama.
So, he's going to go
to bed and he's going
to put his hands sleeping.
And then he's going to
wrap himself in his covers
and then sleep all night.
And then when the morning
comes he opens his eyes
and off come the covers
and then he jumps up
and he's ready for the day.
Okay, so let's do it.
Going to bed.
Llama llama is going to bed,
down on the pillow
he lays his head.
He wraps himself in covers tight
and this is the way
he sleeps all night.
Close your eyes.
Morning comes, he
opens his eyes,
off with a toss, the covers fly.
Soon he's up and
dressed and away,
ready for fun and play all day.
One more time.
Llama llama is going to bed.
Down on the pillow
he lays his head.
He wraps himself in
covers tight, more oh,
and this is the way
he sleeps at night.
Morning comes, he
opens his eyes,
off with a toss the covers fly.
Soon he's up dressed and
ready to, ready away,
ready for fun and play all day.
Okay. [Applause] So now let's do
that old Nursery Rhyme
from mother Goose.
Wee Willie Winkie,
the tune goes--
[ Singing ]
Excuse me.
[Singing] Wee Willie Winkie
comes through the town upstairs
and downstairs in his nightgown.
Knocking at the window,
crying at the lock,
are all the children
in their beds?
Its past 8 o clock.
Wee Willie Winkie runs
through the town, upstairs
and downstairs in his nightgown.
Knocking at the windows
and crying at the look,
are all the children
in their beds?
Its past 8 o'clock.
Okay [Applause] good job.
And now Thea is going to
read another book for us.
>> Thea Austen: Now we're
going to read Llama Llama
and the Bully Goat, also written
and illustrated by Anna Dewdney.
Llama llama busy day, writing,
counting, pictures, clay,
roll a pancake, draw the
Sun, almost everyone has fun.
Time for circle, time for song,
time to clap and sing along.
Kitty, Rhino, Sheep
and Calf, Llama,
Nellie and Giraffe all sing
songs in their own way.
Moo.Bellow.
Baa and Bray.
Llama llama claps the beat,
Gilroy Goat just
points and bleats.
Sheep goes baa, Calf goes Moo,
Gilroy thinks that's silly too.
Llama llama likes to sing.
Gilroy laughs at everything.
Llama sings out just the same.
Gilroy says a not nice name.
Teacher has some things to
say, calling names is not okay.
Being mean is not allowed,
teacher says to stop it now.
Time for recess, go outside.
Monkey bars and slippy slides,
Nelly's dolly makes a road.
Fuzzy Llama pulls a load.
Kids climb up and kids climb
down, everybody runs around.
Nelly's dolly wants to dig.
Fuzzy drives a great big rig.
Gilroy stands in Fuzzy's way.
Gilroy, do you want to play?
Gilroy bleats and
kicks the dirt.
He gets sand on Llamas shirt.
Gilroy throws some
dirt at Nelly, Ha ha!
Gnus are really smelly.
Gilroy pushes, Fuzzy falls.
Ha ha! Llamas play with dolls.
Gilroy snickers,
laughs, and kicks.
Gilroy tosses toys and sticks.
Gilroy stomps on Llamas
coat, Gilroy is a bully goat.
Gilroy, this is not okay.
Stop it or we'll go away.
Being bullied is no fun.
Walk away and tell someone.
Gilroy fusses, frowns and pouts.
Gilroy gets a long time out.
Teacher says, let's try again,
Gilroy can you be a friend?
No more kicking, no more names,
time to play a nicer game.
End of recess, back inside.
Gilroy sits by teachers side.
Everybody sings the song and
this time Gilroy sings along.
Gilroy goat has fun with Llama
but school is over,
here comes Mama.
Tomorrow has more games to try.
See you then.
Friends wave goodbye.
Goodbye. [Applause]
>> Caroline Quandt: Good book.
Alright. So, now we're going to
sing about having good manners
and being kind and caring
with our friends, right?
So this is to I'm
a Little Teapot.
[ Music ]
I have super manners yes I do,
I can say please
and thank you too.
When I play with
friends I like to share
and that's the way
to show I care.
I have super manners, yes I do.
I can say please
and thank you too.
When I play with
friends I like to share
and that's the way
I show I care.
[Applause] Oh good job.
So now we're going to do
a little extended version
of that classic round.
We won't try around though.
Make new friends.
So the tune goes--
[ Music ]
[Singing] Make new
friends, but keep the old,
one is silver and
the others gold.
A circle is round,
it has no ends,
that's how long I want
to be your friend.
A fire burns bright
it warms the heart,
we've been friends
from the very start.
You help me, and I'll help you
and together we will
see it through.
One more time.
[Singing] Make new
friends but keep the old,
one is silver and
the others gold.
A circle is round,
it has no end,
that's how long I want
to be your friend.
A fire burns bright,
it warms the heart,
we've been friends
from the very start.
You help me and I'll help you
and together we will
see it through.
Oh you sound lovely.
[Applause] Alright so now we're
at the end of our story time,
thank you so much Thea and
let's do our goodbye song
which is the opposite
of our hello.
So goodbye is a simple
wave right?
And then we're going
to do the friends
and it's time to say goodbye.
[Singing] Good bye friends, good
bye friends, goodbye friends,
it's time to say goodbye.
Thank you for coming to story
time at the Library of Congress.
Alright. [Applause]
>> This has been a
presentation of the Library
of Congress visit us at loc.gov.